tell us about how would so this saturday
you partied in miami
they shut down miami the curfew what
happened this week
i mean we're going to get into this
topic right now so yeah that's what
happened
okay i'll just give it to you from my
personal experience and then we can kind
of
go go deeper i remember being at this
place called the soho house which is
sort of a local i mean they're
they're in every sort of major city new
york la chicago the private club for me
it's a private club yeah i gotta be
surprised all of your membership type of
things yeah
a little bit cheaper but in certain
certain places but point is
uh we were there hanging out like you
know it's just a weekend chill out
locals
and people start passing around like
alert did you see this alert to see this
it's probably four o'clock in the
afternoon at this point is by the time
we're getting alerts on our phones text
messages
so you start clubbing at four o'clock no
we're just very impressed about where
the beach is just wrapped
up this is not a party scene you're
hanging out by the pool you're having a
beach you're having lunch it's nothing
crazy
um and there's alerts going on they're
saying that the entertainment district
south like the heart of south beach is
shutting down at 8 p.m
shutting down so we're all like i mean
we have dinner plans it's the weekend
now which
mayor shut it down because there's too
many there's a couple mayors
there's a specifically the mayor of
miami beach's name his name is dan
gelber
okay um not mayor suarez he's the mayor
of the city of miami and then there's
the uh a different mayor uh mayor of the
entire miami-dade county
so this was specifically miami beach and
in my opinion this was certainly a
necessary move
like look you're in california you know
that you've been on lockdown
for a full-on year and everyone hates
gavin newsom because
i mean they're recalling knew some
because he's too way too far
left way too locked down you know
precautionary measures
you know people have been praising
florida and our and our friend friend of
the show ron desantis for
you know keeping florida open and
keeping jobs and and bringing business
but this is sort of the ugly side of
staying open so it's the perfect recipe
when you have
you know an open state cheap flights
spring break
stimulus uh pent-up demand
everyone's coming to south beach and in
this certain pocket of
of neighborhood it's the party scene so
in in my opinion what they should have
done differently was not announce it at
three four o'clock on a saturday oh by
the way bedtimes in four hours everybody
are you freaking kidding me they're
already out there on the streets having
a great time partying
say starting tomorrow sunday this is
what we're going to be implementing
late already yeah but it's they they
rolled it out horribly
and i mean people are look people have
been on lockdown for
a freaking year you're telling me you're
getting a 50 flight to miami beach and
usually the hotels are 400 bucks a night
and you're paying
150 and you're coming down with your
buddies and you just got another 1400
in your stimulus because these aren't
spring breakers these aren't like
20 year old college kids it could be 30
year old grown men or just yo i'm trying
to get out get it in women man
and look you know
masks social distancing that's not even
a freaking thing going on right now
you know it's hot out so are you wearing
a mask were you being socially
responsible at the club
of course then i'm actually being honest
no i you know were you wearing like a
nice
look at him i'm just am i trying to hang
out with 10 000 people like at
a freaking concert no but it might
social like look at us right now am i
wearing a mask no but it's not
to me like you know you're you know it's
a messed up situation when
were you wearing a mask is like the
tenth thing to bring up
right like we weren't a mask it's like
there's so many other things going on
here
so and then there's the ugly ugly ugly
side of all this where people are
getting arrested half
i think there's a thousand arrests over
the last few weeks half of them are
out of state people from out of state
thousand arrests in the last few weeks
in miami yes okay and half
over 50 are from out of state so these
aren't locals getting loose
crazy people like tom coming in from
california trying to live it up
yeah can i have a shot at this go for it
go for it
this what a coincidence it's a red state
right where all these arrests are
happening
you just push it back it's a purple
state this is like the most purple state
it goes from red to blue quite
consistent we'll call it i'm gonna look
at this a little bit differently from a
different perspective maybe somebody in
the media or somebody that's a little
bit more skeptical of things
this thing seems staged to me this isn't
just a coincidence where
3 000 people can't handle their alcohol
suddenly on saturday night so they got
to start jumping on cars and
no this is planned i mean i think the
chaos is really
when you see chaos like this in this
country now
there is some level of organization to
it i'm not saying this is
what you mean organization it's not a
coin they keep branding it as spring
breakers going wild like you said these
are not spring breakers they can't
afford to go to south beach
there's no college student on in the
country that says
hey man i'm going to spring break on
south beach they just don't do it they
go to
fort lauderdale they go to destin they
go to fort myers they go where it's
cheap
right where the booze is cheap the
hotels are cheap and where there's other
college kids
these are adults this is see this seems
to me that it's a little bit more
organized and
and and not a coincidence that people
are just happy to go bunkers because the
country's finally open it's been open in
florida a long time they were partying
on
new year's eve and new year's here in in
florida so i don't think it's
i don't think it's that i really go deep
tom go deep go deep that's about it
meaning like who's organizing this what
are you doing
i'm gonna stay with the fact that i
think it's more organized than a random
thing that just happened to break out
politically
organized are you saying like social
action let's let's face it here here
let's face it so so
let's just say give some credence to
tom's point right for the sake of debate
and conversation that will happen okay
who would do that
just think about why would they do that
and who would do that who
ended up getting a ton of praise during
covet at the
end not at the beginning at the
beginning who was god of the christ
cuomo was unbelievably more responsible
than anybody else and knew some
how's cuomo looking today not that fraud
cuomo and deshaun watson are in the same
place right what the hell is that story
about this yeah that's a very weird
story
what's going on there anyways he keeps
actually cuomo's in a different place
than deshawn watson but
similarities they're just going after
espn wrote an article about deshaun
watson
espn typically protects players right
because they tell him
they hit him yesterday and it wasn't i
don't know if you read that or not it's
like 12 different stories
it's unbelievable so but when you look
at cuomo then he gets there and then all
of a sudden the santis is everywhere
and abbott didn't get the credit at the
cpac to be someone that could run for
office
whether he does or not that's on him but
the leading candidate right now is um
desantis so you have to if you think the
same way twitter silenced trump
and everybody silas and trump and
youtube is saying we would consider in
the future bringing trump back and
lifting the suspension google's thinking
about lifting the suspension twitter
said there's no way in the world
and now trump is talking about the fact
that he may start his own social media
company that's been in the talks we'll
talk about that here in a minute
desantis is a leading candidate you got
two people that are leading candidates
for 2024
one is pence one is desantis and trump
is the wild card because no one knows
what he's going to be doing nobody knows
what he's going to be doing
so if there is some credence to that you
have to kind of give a black eye to the
state of florida
and this is one way of doing it now it
wasn't as big as people thought it was
going to be
if that was the case i think it was a
better strategy of doing that
but to go back and say you're shutting
down at four o'clock it's kind of weird
it's kind of like
it's it's as if like you know criminal
activity is happening shut it down panic
it was too much of an abrupt reaction by
the
miami uh uh beach mayor that's different
than
uh is it suarez francis wars is the city
of miami he's the city of miami this is
did you bail did you leave or did you
stick around and see something no i
look i was at i took a mask on he stayed
there
i took a boat to a different part of
town shout out to my
good buddy marco and chris purcello
those guys have a gorgeous place called
joya it's across from fischer
gorgeous place very local scene or new
york tourist definitely not spring break
and people got the pr the biggest
problem was
they shut down all the highways so if
you're like i haven't
they shut down you couldn't get to the
freaking beach
so if you live in miami beach or
you're staying in a hotel and you're
like yeah i was just downtown miami in
wynwood and i
had dinner i saw a family good luck
getting back what are you talking about
it was so
freaking poorly planned and then you add
on top of that like they're shutting
down streets
and then then all the cops are being
moved to the entertainment district
basically between
5th and 16th lincoln road it's all three
blocks ocean drive collins and
washington
if you're familiar with south beach and
there's just partying going on like
crazy so all the cops are going over
there shootings
shootings yeah people shooting bullets
up in the air it was stupid
yeah so i i do here's what i'll say the
the positive i do actually applaud
your mentality thinking what was it
planned
what's going on in my opinion this was
just
fluke idiots just no you're telling
drunk absolutely
you're telling drunk people look at the
video folks four o'clock not drunk
people
drunk people they go what do you mean
i'm telling you they're out there
partying like
people can act this is not the that is
not the action of drunk people people
get drunk in every city people get drunk
in maui
they don't do that all right i'm gonna
give you one question yeah
when's the last time you went out and
partied and drank in south beach
it's very special i have done it uh
when's the last time but i don't know i
mean
a while ago the point is these people
are drinking
their southerners
okay this is the first time people have
been out partying in a year
pent up demand but then do you have a
desire to go to jail and get arrested i
haven't been able to party
look the problem was wasn't so much that
they were partying and drinking it's
that
they're like oh yeah now you got to go
back to your hotel they're like what are
you talking about bro i'm here on
vacation
no no no go back to your hotel i think
there's some people that were probably
in that mode no
they're like what i'm in the middle of
having a great time and you want me to
go to my hotel at 7 30 buddy
not happening and those people are like
[ __ ] that
so case study you take sam with you a
camera i'm going to tom
and take him to south beach
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you